what amazes me about your career you had
set up a line in the sand so to speak
and you said if I don't make it by the
time I'm 30 years old if I'm not a
working actress I'm out of this business
I'm moving into something new and
different right I thought you know I was
doing I was doing production work like I
was a I was a PA and then I was a
production coordinator and I was a
production manager you were a production
assistant on your cousin Jenny Jenny
that was my first job yeah like in that
business I actually learned a lot from
that because we're close with her yeah
we I mean we grew up we grew up together
I mean she lived in the city and I lived
it lived outside but we saw we saw them
on like all the holidays and stuff do
you see do you see her now that she's on
the view we're like will you go to her
way I work probably not but only cuz
we're on you know we're just an opposite
worlds now but it was nice of her to
hire you as a production it was
incredibly nice cuz that's what I wanted
I was like I don't know I don't know
anything about this I don't know how any
of it works I've only been in theater
right and that job literally I think -
every single time I do something today
it's it it's made me better and you were
a production assistant so it was a
little bit of everything everything you
did the garbage you cleaned up you did
craft service you every single thing I
dropped the film at night I was the
first one there in the last one to leave
and it's like I wish I wish everybody
that went into the business had to do
that so to me the greatest story about
you is the day before your birthday you
get the call that week
yeah that you're gonna be you landed a
role on Gilmore Girls which was a big
breakout thing for ya because it ran for
seven years it was the first it was the
first time that I felt like I could say
it was an actor as well as I I could
quit I quit my nanny jobs I quit all the
production jobs so seven years of
Gilmore Girls liberates you you're now a
working actress you can finally hold
your head up high you're getting a sound
it's really great but the next level is
when bridesmaids come beside me it's
kind of did you ever imagine you'd be a
movie star that had eight hundred
million dollars worth of ticket sales I
mean that's is it a really weird
experience I have a smash hit like
bridesmaid and then everyone's coming at
you with scripts and then to decide your
next berry next movie project like
because you know what you've spent so
many years building up to this
and look at 30 you almost quit the
business because it's so hard now you've
got to smash hit now you got everybody
coming at you you almost become
paralyzed with fear right you don't want
to tank well you don't want to take no
there's there's certainly that of like
oh god I didn't please don't let it be
one and done that just seems soul
crushing are you like on a Friday night
sitting there by the phone waiting for
that first report you don't do that no
but is it on your mind it's on my mind
it means somebody will call I just want
to hear like is yes or no is it good
because at that point I think I can't
can I can't control it so it's I would
make myself crazy if I started you know
all those weird like the tracking and of
this and did you know did you hear the
testing and did you I knew the testing
had gone well I'd never really been as
involved in all of that stuff until
Tammy because I you know as a producer
on it right do you ever do you ever go
to your own movies I got an opening
night talk about when the movie opens I
don't mean the premiere do you go and
watch an audience Paul Feig Ben and I
were over at Paul Feig house in his wife
Laurie and you know right but like two
weeks before it was coming out everybody
was super confident and everybody
freaked out the week before and they're
like numbers are going down Suntree it's
not tracking like we thought and I kept
saying it's gonna open great I said it's
too funny and everyone's like we just
want you to be very realistic the
numbers are going down and I said I'm
telling you it's 25 at least they're
like I said it could be up to 30 and
they're like well we know what we're
talking about and that's not gonna
happen yeah and we kept getting worse
and worse calls and I was like I don't
believe any of you and we were literally
having dinner in their backyard and Paul
was watching it and all of a sudden he
was like oh my god oh my god wait a
minute and then literally he's like
we've got to go and we ran to the
theater and like went into all these
different theaters and just stood in the
aisle and like listen to people it's
laughing we were like best feeling he
you could tell he was just like like we
I think we all felt like we knew it was
funny
you